[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone
and welcome to my session i'm going to
be talking about embedding v8
in the real world or more specifically
in the native script framework
my name is tanimira voivo and i'm a
software engineer at progress
i work on this really cool open source
project called nativescript
i'm also a gde for angular and web
technologies and if you want to find me
and talk to me
the best place is on twitter or
in the karaoke after
so native scripts our main topic today
after v8 of course
what is it what is it how many people
here have heard about nativescript
awesome okay nativescript is a framework
for building native mobile applications
for android and ios using web
technologies
like angular vue or just plain
javascript
in short it is a way to execute
javascript in the mobile world and
build mobile applications with it
we will take a short overview of the
architecture of the framework
at the bottom of course we have android
and ios the underlying operating systems
on top of that we have the native script
runtimes
for android and for ios which provide
the 100
native api access but if you ever had to
build a mobile application for android
or ios
you may have noticed that the way to do
that is quite different
like all the apis are different the way
to build your
user interface is different everything
is completely different because there
are two different worlds
that's why nanoscript also provides a
common abstraction
for these apis it is part of the
framework and the native script
developers can use that
in order to build layout or build
user interface or even style their
applications with css
and this layer is written in javascript
and
you can use that so that you can have a
single code base
and have different applications for
android and ios
nanoscript also has a very light
application framework which provides us
with data bindings navigations
and some other cool things and if you
need something a bit more sophisticated
while building your applications
nativescript also supports angular and
vue.js
but today we're going to talk about the
bottom lost levels
the deep stuff and more specifically
we're going to talk about the android
runtime the two runtimes are quite
similar
and the biggest difference between them
is that the android runtime uses v8
under the hood whereas the ios runtime
uses another javascript engine
javascript core but the principle of how
they work is quite
similar
we're going to start by explaining how
the native api access works
as you may have guessed from the name
native script this is kind of what we
mostly brag about because
we have 100 percent api access and this
is why
you should be using nanoscript instead
of
whatever every anything else you choose
the main advantage but how it works
we'll start with the look at the
application package of a nanoscript
application
so we have android some phone or some
device that is running the android
operating system
and the manuscript application is just a
regular android application
which has some native sweep magic inside
it
and the first part of the magic is of
course the javascript code that the
nanoscript developer
wrote and shipped inside that
application the javascript code is not
crosstram spout or
converted or translated or anything like
that it stays javascript
during the whole life cycle while the
application is running
we also have the neriski runtime both
the simplest and the java part we're
going to talk about them
shipped together with inside the
application
and the last part almost is v8
why do we need to ship v8 inside an
android application
well to execute javascript
v8 is a javascript engine it executes
javascript it is embedded in chrome
node even microsoft touch nowadays
and of course in native script it is
actively developed by google it was
created from the chrome browser
and is one of the fastest javascript
engines out there
another reason why we chose v8 is
because it has a pretty cool embedders
api
that we can use and plug into the
runtime
if you want to read a bit more about v8
and how it works i highly recommend
these two resources
resources the first one is a really
amazing blog post series
which is a crash course in just in time
compilers
by link work and the other one is a
video which is
very recent it's called wi-fi script and
it describes
a few of the optimizations that va does
under the hood while
it executes your javascript code it's by
satya and jakob from the va team
so if you want to learn about modern
javascript engines
these are two great resources to get
started
the next part of the naval script magic
the metadata generator
this is a one of very very valid
javascript code
inside natoscript but we have something
that is
not usually in the navscript in the
javascript language right
android where does this come from
well let's imagine that on your computer
you have
some native library for example the
android sdk
and you use that inside your native
script application
while your application is being built
nativescript runs a special tool called
the metadata generator
which traverses that native library and
gets information about the apis
it gets information about audi global
packages about every single class
about how these classes can be
instantiated about every method in
these classes and what are the method
signatures
basically it gets information how every
single
method and api can be used
that information is then saved inside a
compact runtime binary
which is again shipped inside the
application
so we have information about how we can
create
stuff in java inside the metadata
and the metadata of course is shipped
together with the whole application
as well and what happens at lunchtime
we initialize v8 which can execute the
javascript code
we load the metadata from the files that
are saved inside the application
and we attach certain callbacks
and the callbacks are the most important
part
about embedding v8 they're
our way to plug into the javascript code
and do
certain stuff
let's start by explaining some stuff
about these callbacks and how they
actually work together with the metadata
to provide us with access to the native
apis
okay we have this expression android
media media recorder
we're trying to execute that javascript
code
the nascent runtime has read the
metadata and found out that there is
an android global package that's why
it has created a global object inside
the running v8 instance
for android it also has attached some
callbacks to that
object like the package getter callback
so that when we query for android.media
the nameskip runtime plugs in with that
callback the callback will be executed
and inside the callback the netsk
runtime will try to find android.media
inside the metadata
it returns something some information
for example information that
android.media has some media recorder
and it also has a package getter
callback attached
so when that callback is called we find
the media recorder inside the android
media package
in the metadata and this time we return
a constructor function because this is
actually a class
and why is that constructor function so
important well because when it's invoked
with
new it actually contains a constructor
callback
again attached by the nades group
runtime
and this is where the actual magic
happens because the nascent front-end
now
creates a native java object
but how does that happen well
we use jni or java native interface and
this is basically a bridge
between v8 and the running
android runtime so we can send
instructions
back and forth between the two
so we create the native object then we
create the javascript proxy object that
we're going to discuss a bit later
and we return the proxy object to the
javascript world
if we try to access something inside
that proxy
well actually this proxy object is not
very simple it's not a plane object it
creates some callbacks
uh contains some callbacks as well so
when we try to access the same random
field
we know that this field exists in the
java world so that we have attached
a field getter callback and the field
getter callback actually queries the
original java object
but there is a slight complication here
okay we can get the result
from the java world but the data type is
different from the javascript data type
right so java long string
is not something that we can assign to a
javascript variable
and that's why there is a marshalling
service
its role is to convert data from java to
javascript and
vice versa and at this point you may ask
okay
wouldn't that be terribly slow if we try
to convert everything
well yeah obviously it will be because
if we try to convert objects
it's not a good idea this is another
reason why
proxies are quite useful so for objects
we just create a plain javascript object
which has the
the same methods with the same
signatures
and the same members as well
and inside that we have callbacks so
that when you call
some method with the same name on the
javascript object the callback will be
called
and the navskip runtime will call the
original java method through jni
and this is a very cheap operation
creating new javascript objects
instead of converting data
if you call a method same story a method
callback is triggered
[Music]
we call the original java method the
result is marginalized again and it's
returned back to the javascript world if
we have
arguments in that method the arguments
will be converted to
java data format and then there will be
the java method will be called with the
converted
arguments okay let's see
just a quick overview of how these
callbacks are
have confused you so far we try to
instantiate new object and assign that
to
a javascript variable we call the
constructor
the constructor callback the nasd
runtime creates
a new instance of the class through jni
the instance is returned and because
it's an object
the nascent runtimes creates a
javascript proxy object
then we try to call some method on that
proxy
we call actually the method callback
without knowing that we're calling it
everything is hidden it happens behind
the scenes
but the method callback then calls the
original java method
the result that we can get is returned
through jni
and then it's martialized and returned
back to the javascript world
that's all the communication magic that
happens
but you may be wondering at this point
what happens with
these objects like we create javascript
objects we also create java objects
they're connected in some way so we
actually have to take care of the
life cycle and in javascript
we don't have to manually manage the
memory
there is a garbage collector that runs
and its role is to retrieve the memory
of the unused objects
it also has a non-deterministic nature
so we can't really tell for sure when
the garbage collector will run
and the other kind of complication is
that well the android runtime also has a
garbage collector
it's pretty funny so we have two garbage
collectors running we have objects in
both worlds
and that's one of the biggest challenges
of the navsuk runtime
we have to kind of try to synchronize
that
we have to ensure that no object is
collected
if there is a living counterpart for
example if you create some
java object through javascript and then
try to access it
if the android garbage collector
collected the native java object
that's not really cool because you will
try to access something that doesn't
exist
and the application will crash
like it will crash if you're running a
mobile application
it's not it's not really cool user
experience
okay in order to plug in to the
lifecycle we use
finalizer callbacks so that when
the garbage collector of v8 marks
something that
for collecting says that some object
doesn't have living
instances anywhere and it should be
collected
the finalizer callback will be called
and this is the place where dna's
runtime is plugged into
we have strong and weak references let's
see how
these actually look like okay we have
the same example as before
first we create the native object
then we create a javascript proxy
and then the narrative runtime has two
collections
one for strong references and one for
weak references
when the objects are first created we
create a strong
reference or a link if you would like to
call that
between the two objects and
if that's confusing okay the proxy lifts
in side v8
the original object lives inside the
android runtime
and the references live inside the new
script runtime
all right time to collect stuff some
garbage collector runs we can't really
say for sure if it's
gonna be the v8 garbage collector or the
android runtime garbage collector
but let's say in this example that v8
will decide to collect
the memory first so
there is no one in the javascript world
using the
javascript proxy recorder and that's why
it's marked for collection
but at this point the finalizer callback
is called
and the names front time sees that there
is a living strong reference
that's why the strong reference is
turned into a weak reference
and we instruct v8 not to collect that
object
the next time when the android garbage
collector runs
it decides to mark the recorder object
for collection because no one in the
java world is using it
and it sees that there is a weak
reference and because it's a weak
reference
this object will be collected
so let's say that at some time
the v8 garbage collector runs again well
now there is a weak reference
and the weak reference doesn't point to
anything
and because we don't have anything out
there in the java world
this object can also be collected it's
marked for collection and now we can
collect it
but if we had two consecutive garbage
collector
collection runs inside v8 and
we still had a weak reference to a
living object that wasn't created by the
java garbage collector
the v8 object would wouldn't have been
collected as well
so this is a normal cycle
and as you could imagine there are some
challenges that happen because we have
to running
garbage collectors well we could get
out of memory exceptions usually the
objects that are created in the android
application are not really big so
we wouldn't have that happening for a
hello world application right but
the problem is that of course yeah we
have a few garbage collection cycles
that should be run in order for some
memory to be retrieved back
and if we create some big objects this
can cause problems
because the memory is not retrieved on
time
for example we can have images
and an image let's say that that's this
java array in the java world the java
array is quite big
whereas the javascript proxy is not so
big it's actually just a plain
object with some callbacks attached so
it actually looks like that
memory wise we have a lot of memory in
the java world
we have a really plain javascript proxy
and the java the android garbage
collector is actually dependent
on the v8 garbage collector in order to
retrieve this
huge chunk of memory
so at this point the v8 garbage
collector even if you have
tens of thousands of these small plane
proxies
it doesn't have pressure to be run
because
we don't really take a lot of memory in
the
running javascript virtual machine
so va doesn't really have a reason to
trigger garbage collection
and if that doesn't happen on time well
we may
cause out of memory exceptions
because we're taking too much space in
the java virtual machine
some solutions are more like strategies
to
overcome this because there is no
straightforward
deterministic solution because of the
nature of the problem
the first one there is a api provided by
v8
that lets us
instruct v8 about the memory that is
allocated
inside of it so in our case we can take
say to v8 okay the android application
that is running
actually uses this amount of memory and
this memory
is used because you have created some
javascript objects and the javascript
objects are still pointing
to living instances in the java world
so this should hint v8 to run garbage
collection more often because it's more
aware that there is some memory that
should be freed
but it doesn't really i mean it works in
practice but
we can still get out of memory
exceptions
another important thing we're doing this
internally inside the network runtime
so the next developers don't have to use
that
and it is a technique used
internally another solution we can force
garbage collection of course
we can say v8 come on run garbage
collection
mark these objects as free to be
retrieved
make these strong references weak then
we can run
the android garbage collector and then
we can run
the v8 garbage collector again and this
is not the best thing ever because
it doesn't guarantee that the garbage
collection will be run it just kind of
schedules it or
hinted that it should be run but we
don't have a guarantee that it will be
run
and you don't have a guarantee that it
will be run in that order as well
also it's obviously not the cheapest
operation out there like
you're traversing a huge tree of objects
and you're checking if there
have living references it may have the
opposite effect
so this is not the best solution ever
like you can do it it is some strategy
but we don't really recommend
using that
okay let's take a look at this again we
have a strong reference
what if we didn't have references and
what if we had the control
over saying like
this java object can be collected
because i'm not using it anymore in the
javascript
world well
the nascent prontem exposes a function
called release native counterpart
and we need to provide the proxy object
and what happens basically is
destroys all these references
so we invoke that we basically instruct
that we're no longer using this
native object and it can be retrieved
so whenever the next android garbage
collector runs
it is no longer dependent on v8's
garbage collector
it can mark this object as unused and it
can safely retrieve it
and as the last part of the presentation
something like
a bit simpler multitrading
what is the point well the javascript
code in native script is
run executed on a single thread which
actually happens to be the main user
interface thread
and if you see where i'm going this can
cause some problems with
luck and junk so
you can see some glitches while your
mobile application is
being used and this is not the best
experience for a native mobile
application as well
so first yet you know what is junk
probably it is the percentage of frames
that are dropped
while you are doing some calculations
we're not going to focus on that it's
important to know that in the nanoscape
application if you're just building user
interface
you're actually creating native android
and ios
widgets so you shouldn't experience junk
in a
native list view when you're scrolling
for example
if you're creating animations it's the
same thing
you have many ways of creating
animations in manuscript with
angular with css with javascript but
internally it's actually creating native
android applications
so you shouldn't have any problem while
running application
animations the other thing that is
commonly
uh we're commonly asked for if you're
creating an http request
well the plugin that you're going to use
creates a background
thread in the java world which wouldn't
freeze the manual
ui thread but you may see some junk
when you're executing cpu intensive
operations
and the same thing could happen if
you're executing cpu intensive java code
in an android application
so what is the solution well worker
threads essentially background threads
in the javascript world which wouldn't
block the main ui thread
the api is based on the web workers api
we don't have javascript memory sharing
but we have way to communicate between
the worker threads and the main ui
thread
and final thing i'm going to ask you a
question so you have to be patient for
30 more seconds what is a worker trait
in native script
okay two hints first
is it an isolate isolate is va's way to
isolate and execute some memory
uh sorry to isolate some memory for a
code that is being executed
the israelis can run in parallel and we
don't have memory sharing
context one isolate can have multiple
contexts
we don't have memory isolation and we
can't run contexts in parallel
also you have to explicitly specify the
context that some code is being executed
on
isolates or contexts isolates
contexts okay wasn't gay isolate
okay it's an isolate cool
all right so this was about manuscript
and v8
if you want to meet me afterwards you
can find me
in twitter and i'll be coming to you
and i also want to thank my colleague
vladimir muntafu who helped me with this
presentation and this is his handle on
twitter as well
so thanks a lot
[Music]